foreign
minute Monday is stand up for somebody
find somebody around you this week Who's
down on their luck who may have been
attacked by somebody who who doesn't
believe in himself anymore and stand up
for them and let them know that they
should keep going that you believe in
them or that they have a supporter in
you a quick example I recently made a
video about Gary vaynerchuk Gary is
somebody who I look up to somebody who I
enjoy his channel uh somebody we've done
some projects together with I love his
stuff but he gave one answer on his
YouTube channel that really bothered me
a guy named Raphael wrote in and asked
him for advice on building a personal
brand and Gary just shot him down and
said shut your mouth don't say anything
for 10 years and it just didn't sit well
with me you know I'm and because I'm the
guy who's all about believe
I felt like Raphael deserved a better
answer so I made a video and in the
video I gave Rafael some personal advice
from my experience and also said that
garyvee gave a douchebag answer I love
Gary's stuff I love everything that he
stands for for the most part but in that
one instance maybe he's having a bad day
he gave a douchebag answer and so I
stood up I stood up for Raphael and and
Raphael wrote in and said thank you so
much I'm gonna keep going I love the
suggestions and I helped him make
progress on his goal to change the world
and so I want you to do that for
somebody today you know that that that
was a great personal risk to me I don't
want to piss off Gary vaynerchuk you
know maybe we're going to do some more
projects together in the future but it
was the right thing to do find somebody
who may be picked on who may be down in
their luck who may not believe in
themselves anymore and stand up for them
and let them know that they've got
somebody in the corner who's cheering
them on who wants to see them succeed
it'll make you feel great it'll make
them feel great and it's the right thing
to do
belief
information join my newsletter and get
on the believe team today
hi I'm Jason J Ross Fonseca of
rizonline.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period